hey how you doing my name's samuel i'm a
property investor and right now i'm
going to be answering your
property investment questions and
whether that's around
mortgages tax buy to let hmos
sharia law we've got some really
interesting questions
from last week's video so i'm going to
do my best to answer your questions from
last week
however if you're watching right now
please
ask your questions below in the comment
box and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to try my very best
to answer your questions on my next q a
sunday video at 7 p.m so get asking your
property questions ask
right now anything at all that is like
holding you back
or if you've always wondered something
about property or being
a property millionaire or doing rent to
rent hmos service accommodation lease
options whatever it might be
now's your chance to ask below also
don't forget to
smash the like button if you could do
that for me that'd be really helped me
out as a youtuber it helps
share the algorithm to the youtube gods
so that more people get to see the video
so help me out
hit the like button subscribe and let's
see what questions we have got
so last week we had a guy called hugh
hubert williams who said
hi samuel i'm 16 i've been watching you
for the last three years living in essex
where properties are expensive i've
bought your books
and i'm planning on buying your
mentorship courses and my father is
happy
to take properties for me in his name i
just want to know
what would you advise for my next steps
great stuff so hugh
you remind me very much of me when i was
16 i was 16
i was starting out i was going on
different courses my stepdad
agreed as well to put properties in his
name for me
and what i did was i got really good
first thing you need to do you need to
get really good
at finding deals if you can find really
good property deals
that's that's what you need because if a
good deal
you'll be able to attract attract the
investment
you're about to get the finance on a
good deal banks will want to lend on it
angel investors will want to lend on it
people oh excuse me people will want to
come and join venture on the deal
your dad is happy to be a a guarantor so
to speak
now what i did probably probably the
wrong way was
my stepdad he put it in his name but we
actually had no written agreement
between us
as far as legally was concerned they
were just his properties
so my first house that i bought he
hosted it for me
um it became a little bit of a problem
later on because
when i wanted to switch it to my name i
had to literally buy it off him
for the amount of the mortgage so it was
like i normally down
but i ended up having to play stamp duty
on it and it was just a little bit
not great also the property did double
in value
and even though you love your dad and
i'm sure you trust your dad and it's a
really good gesture that he's offered
if you buy a property and you raise the
money and you buy it and he hosts it in
his name and then that property
shoots up in value he might
change his mind he might say well look
you know i know we agreed this but and
so just be really clear i mean there's
different ways you could do it you could
potentially do something called tenants
in common
which is where um listen speak
speak i could spend a lot of time
talking about this but i would say
you've got great setup get good at
finding deals speak to a mortgage broker
and speak to an accountant just about
how to
test structure it um i hope that helps
good job
darwin goodyear says i've currently got
50 000 pounds to invest
would you advise to go into brr deal or
invest into something like a rent to
rent
i'm patient for cash flow but would
rather make a large sum of money on the
right deal
than get and then get cash flow as a
bonus
um i think it depends on what your goal
is if i
if i had 50 000 pounds and i wanted to
invest in property it depends
exactly i mean i mean if you're in a job
that you hate
which hopefully darwin is not because
darwin works for me
but if you're in a job that you really
don't like um and you just want to get
out as fast as possible
then it might make sense to put a
portion of that money maybe 10 000
pounds or something
into rent to rent to get some instant
cash flow and you focus
more on instant cash flow if you like
your job
and you're happy you're thinking about
just building wealth and growing your
portfolio
then it might make sense to put the
fifty thousand pounds into into
the portfolio but i feel like there's a
conflict of interest of me giving advice
right here right now
because darwin is a member of my staff
who's actually behind the camera
um who always you know what he always
does this because he'll we'll be driving
he's my videographer and he'll say to me
send me out do you know when you do a
property video and i'll go
and then ask me a question i'll say
that's a really good question you know
what and you'll go yeah and i'll say
this sunday at 7 pm he's like yeah i'm
like i'm doing a q a
right crack your joke thing but anyway
if you've got questions
whether you work for me whether you're
one of my students whether you're brand
new today
comment below did that happen that
helped their darwin good
all right brandon carr i'm wanting to
get into property and property investing
and i'm starting a job as an estate
agent is this a good idea to get me into
property so i can learn all the ropes
i think it is a good idea yes um
if you're young and you know you you you
feel like doing good job as an estate
agent i did this i worked for bestow
eaves countrywide i did it for about
three or six months
i did learn quite a lot as an estate
agent i learned how to speak to estate
agents
i didn't learn about property investing
in a state agency they'll teach you how
to be a good estate agent
they'll teach you how to sell houses
how to sell homes not houses to
investors
how to sell homes i think it will give
you a good foundation for sure
but you're not going to learn how to be
a property investor as an estate agent
otherwise all estate agents
would be property investors but they're
not i know people that have worked in
the state agency for 20 30 years
and they make 25 grand a year and that's
their job so
don't think that you're going to learn
all the skills to become a property
investor
but you're definitely going to learn
some things and it's going to be fun
and you'll realize how hard it is as
well i mean geez i found it
it's hard work i much prefer being a
property investor than an estate agent
josh christmann says what are your
thoughts on university
i'm first year in college and weighing
up my options
it depends on what you want out of life
man if if you want to be
a property investor if that's your dream
there is no point going to university to
learn how to be a doctor
don't make any sense so i think a lot of
people go to university and they spend
40 000 pounds getting loads of into
loads of student debt
and then they get a job but actually
that's not what they want to do but they
think oh yeah i'll do that and i'll have
my safety blanket
and then when i've got my nice comfy
safety blanket then i'll go and be a
property
investor or property entrepreneur
actually that safety blanket
will really just mean that you end up
becoming a rat
in the rat race and it's going to be
it's going to be harder and harder and
harder
you're going to end up with a mortgage
then a car then
then then you get married then you've
got kids now you
you need this job
why spend three years at university
learning to get a job then
then spending years depending on this
job forget it
if you want to be a property or
entrepreneur
just do it now so
but if you want to be a doctor yeah go
to university
all right sm says my question is about
buy to let mortgage interest and
arrangement fees as a general rule
do you always go for the lowest interest
rate with the higher arrangement fee
added to the loan amount
or do you think it's better to go for a
slightly higher interest rate with a
lower arrangement fee
i understand you can calculate which is
better deal over a fixed period but i'm
unsure
as to the longer term implications and
how to decide what's best overall any
guidance would be
greatly appreciated thank you depends
it depends on right now it depends on
how much cash you've got so if
if if you've not got much money you want
to just put as little down as possible
and you're happy to pay a little bit
more each month and that's fine
um i do what works out best return on
investment
so i just look at a return on investment
is
how much annual profit are you going to
make well if your interest rates are
higher
then your annual profit is going to be
less because your
your rent you have to pay more interest
so your profits less
so i would take option one my annual
profit
and then i'd divide that by the total
investment that was needed
and see what the return on investment
was then i do option two
okay well if i go with the other option
how much am i going to put down how much
am i going to make profit divide the two
together
and just see what the higher return on
investment with is and usually the one
that gives me the higher roi cash on
cash return on investment is the one
that i go for
all right tamiya reality would you buy
an ex council house
yeah sure as long as it was
standard concrete construction um yeah
silver ltc how can you buy a house and
be sharia compliant i saw this question
um listen uh i'm not a muslim i'm a
christian so i'm not
a hundred percent on all the different
um you know sharia laws but i know that
a lot of our students who are muslim
they can't take out
bank loans or standard mortgages because
as part of
their religion they can't buy interest
on debt which is great
uh no problem at all so for the little
understanding that i have
on islam with the rich
understanding that i have on property
i'll answer the question best i
can and that would be number one
you don't need to buy buy to that
properties to be a
property entrepreneur or whatever like
there's a lot of strategies
where you don't need to do that like
deal sourcing and rent and rents and
stuff
however and also there are investors
that you can go in together with on
joint ventures so you could
find a cash rich investor and go into
business with them you're not borrowing
from them
they're putting the money down you're
finding the deal and doing all the work
and then you're taking a profit share on
any future profits
uh there are lenders that will lend
i don't know exactly how it works but i
know that there are islam banks
so i'll probably get i'll probably get
one of my students because i've got many
who are muslim that have a real rich
understanding on both property and
um the the laws or maybe we could have a
conversation and discuss what happened
if that would be helpful so that's it
now
it's a wrap i hope you found this um
little q a session really helpful
i really look forward to hearing your
questions that you've got for me next
week if you haven't asked a question yet
do it right now don't forget to
subscribe hit the like button
and i'll see you guys next time thanks